>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Yasmeen Khan: I'm conducting
an oral history on behalf
of the American Folklife Center
of two North Indian or
Hindustani musicians.
Sarod master Soumya Chakraverty
and tabla master Debu Nayak.
Previously, they played at the
Library of Congress as part
of the Homegrown concert series
in May during Asian-American
heritage month and [inaudible]
of the American Folklife Center,
co-sponsored by the Library
of Congress Asian-American
Association.
And now, we'll turn
to the questions.
And I'd like them to tell me a
little bit about their early life
and how they got to the point
of becoming master musicians.
And we'll start with you Soumya.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Thank you Yasmeen.
And thank you for the introduction.
So, I-- And I could talk a lot
about how I got into music,
but the simple answer that comes
to my mind, and I think that echoes
with a lot of people of my
generation from South Asia,
is they were kind of forced
into getting to music.
And I used the word
forced into, because that--
it seems like a coercion
technique at that point in time.
But then, that coercion
unbeknownstly became a matter
of love and falling in
love with the art form.
Just like people are sent to
schools and, you know, apparently,
I was brought into music.
But for me, it's a little bit of
coercion plus also enticement.
So, I come from a family
where I didn't have a
musical heritage with me.
But, my parents were
both interested in music.
They used to attend concerts,
festivals, et cetera.
And I have two siblings,
both older than me,
and also had other extended
family members living with us.
And everybody was doing some
sort of music, playing some sort
of instrument or the other.
And mostly, it was
string instruments
like violin, sitar, sarod, vocal.
And they were missing
a tabla player.
So, I sat-- And I was
enticed by the concept
of rhythm having heard live
concerts and as well as recordings.
So, I started jumping in and
started keeping the beat.
And how would I keep the beat,
because I didn't have
tablas with me.
So, I had two metal containers
of cereal boxes and baby food.
So, those are my--
the dayan and bayan.
And I use to sit and
play tabla with them.
So, that was my initiation
into music.
Seeing my level of
interest, my parents decided
that maybe I should have a tabla.
And so, I was-- I started learning
tabla at the age of eight, I think.
And also have a brief stint learning
western violin at school because,
you know, I thought it was cool
to, you know, go to chapel.
I actually studied in a Episcopal
Methodist school in India.
And we had chapel service every
Monday and there was music along it.
So, I was very interested in the
chorale singing and the violin play.
So, my exploration into western
music also started at the same time.
And I learned tabla for
about a year and a half.
And, I can't say if I was very
good at it, but the concept
of rhythm came to my mind.
And, around 11, I actually
switched over to the sarod.
How that happened?
I don't, again, know.
That may have been
an act of coercion.
It's been so many years, I
can't quite remember vividly.
But, it took me a little bit of
time switching from the tabla
to the-- to a string instrument.
But when it did happened
over a course of maybe three,
four years of just readapting
to learning another instrument.
And because of playing the sarod,
and I'll say why a little bit
later during the interview,
I had to give up on the
tabla and the violin.
Because I, you know,
[inaudible] to go play the sarod.
But, so, ultimately, the tabla
and the violin both diminished
and sarod became my
primary instrument.
So, that, in short, is my journey.
And how the journey began
almost, I would say,
37 years ago and it still continues.
>> Yasmeen Khan: That's great.
And how-- What's it about the
sarod that really attracted you?
I mean, what made you give up
the other two and choose this?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Again, at
that point, when you're a boy of 10
or 11 years old, you just do
what your parents tell you.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And,
one day it's like, hey,
you know, you learn sarod.
And then, the other day it is the--
or maybe you start with the tabla,
and then you learn the sarod.
But that being said,
there were certain aspects
of the instrument that attracted me.
I think the sarod and the sitar
are probably the most common string
instruments in India, or
at least in Northern India.
And I always felt that there was
a-- the gender gap between the--
those two instruments, the sarod
with its very deep sound kind
of sounded like a male, very
macho kind of an instrument.
And what-- the ability to do a
lot of fast runs and, you know,
the patterns like the
tabla was very masculine.
On the other hand, I heard
the sitar beautiful as it is,
I just felt more bias
towards the sarod.
And that may have, you know,
propelled me in that direction
plus some gentle cajoling
from my parents.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
Always helps.
And you Devapriya?
>> Devapriya Nayak:
Where do I start?
My mom says that I started
playing when I was two
and a half, three years old.
So, I did purposely
asked her this question,
but when did you noticed me play?
She said that, you
know, when you're two,
two and a half you've
been always hitting
against one thing against the other.
And then, anything you get
you just start drumming on it.
So, those days, it used to
be sort of like customary
that when the summer vacation
comes-- I grew up in Kolkata.
And my parents-- my father,
was in the West Bengal
Civil Service in Bengal.
And so, when the summer time
comes, the holiday will start
and we will go to my ancestral home,
which is 76 to 80 kilometers
from Kolkata.
It's a place called Punjab gharana
and it's a small principality,
where my grandfather and
his ancestry came from there
and it's nothing but music.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Really.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So, my
mom came from this family
and as she put it many times
that music to me is in my blood.
So but, I don't know how this
particular instrument got ingrained
or I got sort of like,
drawn towards it.
And then there are so many other
instruments which I was exposed to.
My mother, she is a fantastic
sitar player when she was young.
And, she played until, you
know, she was in her late 60's.
But, coming back to when we used
to visit the ancestral home,
I used to see my grandfather
practice,
his brothers are practicing, either
sitar, vocal, surbahar, jaltarang,
tablas, pakhavaj and flute.
So, all these instruments were
being, you know, I was exposed to.
And, I have seen my grandfather
was teaching three things.
One, he used to first start the
morning with the vocal, and then,
as he's playing vocal
he would play tabla,
but I was always drawn
towards tabla.
So, he saw this interest
in me and he said--
and while he was playing and
singing, other students gathered
around him, and they
were all just singing.
And some of them are either doing
it on their leg or they're doing it
like this or they're
just doing this.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
Just to keep the beat.
I got-- I don't know how, but
I somehow got drawn into this.
And sooner or later, I
can't put my finger on it.
But sooner or later,
a set of drums came
into the picture and
I started playing.
So nobody really taught me, "OK,
this is what you do to
play-- do this sound.
Or this is what you do to do
this sound, or this sound."
It was just-- I mean,
naturally came to me.
So before you know it, I was
already playing with them.
And this continued for years.
I don't know when it stopped.
But eventually, they
saw the interest
in me, my-- both my parents.
More-- so my-- From my mother side
and then, my father was very busy.
So she, at some point, when we moved
to Kolkata from one summer vacation,
she introduced me to a maestro
who was teaching close to my home.
His name is Radhakanta Nandi.
And he was coming close
to my home to teach.
And I got into that class and,
you know, we started learning
and there-- so, there are a lot
of neighborhood kids
too learning tabla.
But I somehow started excelling
in tabla and I would play
with different instruments.
Probably, because I was playing
in my ancestral home and bringing
that knowledge, playing with other
instruments as well as vocal,
as well as, you know, the
intricacies that goes with it,
I'll bring all of that
and then put in practice.
So that's pretty much
how it happened.
And, you know, eventually I've--
as I aged, slowly, slowly,
I was exposed to different
conferences, concerts and so on.
So, that also has a lot of,
you know, influence on me.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Do you continue--
How does that work into music?
Do you follow the school
of your first tabla teacher
or how do you decide what
style your tabla play or is--
I mean, when you talk about your
musical pedigree, how do you--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- how
do you talk about that?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
When you're learning it initially,
you don't worry about any of that.
You just blindly follow
your teacher, OK,
whatever the teacher
is singing or playing.
We learned two things
simultaneously,
the vocal part and the rhythm part.
So, how does-- in may case at
least, how does, with a song
or how does with-- how does rhythm
fit into a vocal piece so to speak.
We call it Bandish.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: In a Bandish,
how does the vocal part goes?
What is the rhythmic pattern in it?
What is the-- they call it-- in
the tabla term, it's called theka.
How does the theka takes
shape in a Bandish?
So, that's how I learned.
Now, coming back to the question
of schooling, I mean, later on,
I came to know that there
are six schools in tabla.
But the school that I was learning
with my grandfather was Punjab.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: The school
that I came to learn later
on in Kolkata was Benares.
So, I did not notice the
style-- stylistic difference,
except when certain syllables,
much later I realized it,
that there are some
differences in finger techniques.
And we-- Initially,
when we're learning
in my ancestral home following it
blindly, when I came to Kolkata
after the holidays, we
will follow that blindly.
So somehow, a style of my own got
created and I just ran with it.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And what--
How would you answer that
question about, you know,
your musical lineage
in terms of style?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
how you, you know,
at this point, get to this point?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So, I--
My creating has differed slightly
from Debu's that because
I pretty much learned
from one person belonging
to one school.
We also have at least three
different musical lineages
for sarod, our schools.
But because my training, even
to this day that if I've picked
up nuances, it has stayed
within our school of--
and our school comes
from a small village
in northern India called
Shahjahanpur,
named after the Emperor Shah Jahan.
And the Shahjahanpur technique
is very different from some
of the other techniques, one being
Gwalior, again, named after a place,
which the famous maestro of
Sarod, Amjad Ali Khan belongs to.
And also, Maihar, which was a
much later school but founded
by the father of, again, the
legendary Ustad Allaudin Khan.
So, these schools have different
playing techniques, but--
and I've heard them and
like he said, as we grow up,
when you are learning you just
follow what is taught to you,
but as you grow up and as you
listen to different forms of music
and different playing techniques,
you start to discern
those differences
and either you can invite
them or you can choose
to retain your own specific flavor.
I think, with the advent
of electronic music,
what has happened is the knowledge
sharing has become more profound.
It used to be pretty much, you
know, based on the formal training
that one has from a teacher, and
say, if I learn a composition
or a particular raag, I would have
learned it from my guru or teacher.
Now, I can just go on to an
electronic medium like YouTube
and can hear some compositions.
And if I like it and I have the
capability of picking it up,
I do pick it up and I can play it.
Personally, I still believe
in somewhat keeping the
formal school lines just
because these differences that--
the lines would get blurred,
but those differences, I
think, existed for a reason.
And somewhere deep down I
believe in preserving that lineage
and being homaged to
the great maestros
that founded those
techniques and kept those.
Now, as-- if I want to play
something outside of my school,
I can but I should recognize and
acknowledge it that this comes
from a different school rather
than what I formally trained.
>> Devapriya Nayak: That's true.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So, that's a
long-winded answer, but hopefully,
that kind of explains how we kind
of respect each other's
boundary in terms of the schools.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah, and
it's kind of difficult to do
that nowadays because
there's such a--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- the word
for it in Hindi is [inaudible].
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
It's a-- it is a
>> Yasmeen Khan: It's sort
of a mashup that is always--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
A mismatch, yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- possible.
>> Devapriya Nayak: With the
way Zakir Hussain described
when I was learning from him--
>> Yasmeen Khan: From Zakir Hussain?
>> Devapriya Nayak:
From Zakir Hussain,
and this is again different
style from Punjab.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: I came back
to Punjab much later again.
In between, I went to
Farukhabad also and still do.
But Zakir Hussain explained
this as cocktail gharana.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Cocktail gharana.
Cocktail lineage.
So now, it would be nice to
sort of segue into having each
of you talk a little bit about
your instruments and sort
of situate them in, you know,
the history of this particular--
and how it-- musical instrument
and how it is changing.
If it's changing or if you adapt
it on an individual level if it,
you know, how versatile these
are to change and in adaptation.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So,
the history of the sarod probably
goes back about 200 to 300 years.
You know, when you consider how old
Indian music is, it doesn't seem
that old, probably just, you
know, somewhere on the middle
of the British era in India that
the sarod formally took its place.
And there are many theories of
how the instrument came to being.
Some said it was adapted from
other Indian instruments,
some say it has its roots
in Persia and Afghanistan
and even, you know, Middle East.
And the fact is that, I think,
everybody is true to
a certain extent.
There are certain aspects
of the instrument
that when you hear the instrument
or you look at its shape,
you find similarities with
other string instruments
like the tar, the rubab, the oud--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Could you be
specific about that in terms of--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
In terms of the fact that there's a
hollow air chamber, that there's a--
you know, ultimately
at the end of the day,
any kind of plucked instrument is
a piece of string or some pieces
of string that are one
between two knotted areas.
So, you've got a peg, you've
got a, you know, eye here.
But most of these instruments, the
tar, the rubab have a similar type
of shape, a very rounded or somewhat
elliptical, in certain cases,
a drum which has an air chamber
that amplifies the music
and then a finger plate.
And they tend to be
fretless instruments.
The instruments that were
traditionally developed
in India were fretted instrument.
Most notably was the a
whole family of veenas.
The veena is a instrument that's
made from two large pieces of gourd
which grows abundantly in India
and that's attached to a bamboo
or wooden finger board and
they have frets in between
and with the strings tightened
on both sides or by pegs.
Now, because of these two
large gourds, it's kind of held
in an upright position and played.
Now, there are obviously,
variances of these
but the veena produces
a very deep sound
that is amplified by the gourds.
When there were some Afghan
musicians who were the rubabias,
the rubab players,
they came to India.
The rubab, if you look at a picture
of it and I wish I had a photo
to show you, it is actually
almost like a miniature version
of the sarod, looks very similar.
The only difference is the drum
is elliptical and doesn't have
as many strings, does
have a few strings
and the strings are made
of either gut or silk.
And the-- Because the air chamber is
much shallow and also much smaller,
the instrument have a very
dull, kind of a blunt sound.
But I would also say it's a
little bit more earthy in nature.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Wasn't it
also an accompany on a--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: It is.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- a
vocal accompaniment?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: It is
a vocal accompaniment mainly
as a folk instrument.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And because
of there was not a lot of sustenance
in the note, it had this
kind of dull clangy sound.
It was used to-- as almost like to
keep the beat and in some cases,
acted like a percussion, although
not a percussion instrument.
So, if you listen to a lot
of Middle Eastern music,
you'll hear their rubab being
extensively played even today.
So, these were the
rubabias that were like--
they were marching band
instrumentalists that came to India
and they settled down
somewhere in northern India.
And they heard cork musicians
in northern India playing the
veena and also local music.
And they got this idea of
experimenting with the instrument
to make it sound more like a voice
and to have build more sustenance.
So in order to do so,
they start to experiment,
make it a slightly bigger instrument
with the expansion
of the air chamber.
So, you can see this camel hump, as
we call it, to expand this in a way
that it hollows out and
connects with the broader drum.
Now, what that does, it
creates more resonance
and also the strings got replaced
with the advent of metal strings
when the metal drawing techniques
and metal strings being available
for piano and for other instruments.
Metal strings became
popular somewhere, I think,
I'm thinking 18th century and
even maybe later at 19th century,
and they started to use them on the
sarod as well as other instruments.
Now-- And the cover on the
drum, it's a sheep-skin color.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Because the size
of the air chamber being increased
and also another additional
air chamber-- this is all--
serves both as the rest as well as
a kind of an additional air chamber.
The sound of the sustenance
of the string [music]
increased significantly.
And that allowed a lot of
melodic work to be performed
which we could not do
if you played in a--
with an instrument that didn't
have as much sustenance.
So, what started to happen--
and then, the addition
of these little strings
that go underneath the
bridge, the main bridge,
which are called the sympathetic
strings and they are for resonance.
They're not actually plucked but
when you play a note by, you know,
this-- being in the same
frequency, it starts to vibrate.
And by the vibration it
accentuates the melody.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And were those
adopted from sitar or veena?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: They were
used in the veena, the surbahar
and also some of the other
types of rubabs that existed.
The precursor to the sarod
was another instrument called
the sursringar.
And if you look at it today, it
still is played in some provinces
in northern India, mainly the
Sikh religion, they use it.
The rubab and the sursringar are
used for Sikh religious chanting
and they have sympathetic
strings, and they--
that's where the sarodias
or the rubabias originally,
they started to get this idea.
So, after a few rounds
of metamorphosis,
they created an instrument, which
is very different by the way
from the sarod that you see today.
And the-- So, initial sarods had a
very elliptical drum and the depth
of the air chamber was not as much.
But over course of time,
with more experimentation,
there was more resonance
added to it.
And it continue-- To
answer your question,
yes, it continues to evolve.
There have been many
different variations added,
like this rounded drum finally
came through the Maihar gharana.
Although, I belong to
the Shahjahanpur gharana,
I play this round drum instrument,
which is an experimentation
that was [inaudible] and
made this drum more round,
thereby having a more
rounded and deep sound.
And, you know, these days with
the advent of electronic music,
there's also, you know,
experimentation going
on with making electronic
versions of the sarod, which again,
I would call out back
if there's difference
between an acoustic guitar
and a classical guitar.
Their sound is very different
instruments, they are both guitars
but they are very different
instruments.
And likewise, the electric sarod
and the regular classical sarod
are very different instruments.
So, that's a bit about my--
well this instrument, obviously,
there's a lot of technical
details I can go into.
But I'll see if you have
any other questions.
>> Yasmeen Khan: We'll move on to
Debu for now and then come back.
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK.
So regarding tabla, tabla is
relatively in the annals of history
with other Indian percussive
instruments,
a relatively young instrument.
It happened-- In other words,
a tabla came to India as part
of probably the Muslim
invasion that took place
in many times in the Indian history.
But it came around-- and there are
again, different school of thoughts,
it came around between
13th and 14th century.
And during these invasions
from Persia to India,
a lot of learned men and
philosophers and musicians,
they also came and they remained in
India, never went back with them.
One of these, I call
it saint or musicians
so to speak was Amir Khusrow.
>> Yasmeen Khan: All right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
And he was a poet also.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
And he wrote many--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Many music, yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: -- many--
he created many musical
instruments as well.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
So, and there are--
Anyway, there are different
school of thoughts
about Amir Khusrow being
the creator of tabla or not.
So, Amir Khusrow, one thing
they're, you know, and they do agree
on that here is a guy who came from
Persia and studied Indian music.
And how did he do that?
By going to different places.
And one of the areas that he
went was he used to listen
to the Hindu chants in the temples.
And with the chants came a lot
of the musical chants
that he used to observe.
And he used to observe,
not only the chants,
the way the melodic
structure was coming through,
he also used to observe the musical
instruments that are being played
with these melodies and chants.
One such instrument
is called pakhawaj.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yes.
I heard this apocryphal
story of that.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
And pakhawaj is known
as the mother of tabla.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Why?
Because pakhawaj used to be
part of the particular type
of genre called dhrupad sangeet.
And dhrupad used to be called
the original classical form
of vocal music.
And pakhawaj used to
be played, still does,
and the people play
pakhawaj with it.
But Amir Khusrow looked
at that instrument
and he had a different idea.
He thought that--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Maybe you
should describe what the pakhawaj
looks like.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah,
what it looks like?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Well,
the pakhawaj is a cylindrical
instrument, OK.
So, if I put it bluntly,
it will look like this.
So, if you put it sidewise, it
will have a bigger head to play it
like this in a sidewise
way and played like this.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And
it's played with a slap.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
the slap, et cetera.
But, you know, I will come
to that when I will explain
to you the way the
finger techniques evolved.
So, what happened was--
his idea was,
this instrument could
be played better
if we sit in an upright position.
Now, the geographical location
of Amir Khusrow at
this point was Delhi.
And because he came up with
this instrument in Delhi,
the Delhi gharana started.
So, Delhi school of tabla
playing started and the first guy
in recorded history that we know
of, his name is Siddhar Khan.
And Siddhar Khan belong to
Delhi and he was living close
to where Amir Khusrow's dargah
was, where he used to live.
And Siddhar Khan picked it up and
he started playing it and sooner
or later, a school was formed.
Delhi gharana started.
And as he was, you know, as the
school was getting older and older,
different students came to learn
from him and then they would learn
from him and they would
find their own way
to tweak the instrument and so on.
Speaking of the instrument
itself, the first instrument
in recorded history as I know it
is made of wood as pakhawaj was.
He just cuts it into half,
put it in an upright position
and made it a bassy sort
of sound on the left hand
and on the right hand,
a sharper sound.
The instrument is made
out of rawhide from goat
or sheep from-- the same for here.
And these straps are
also from the same--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Material.
>> Devapriya Nayak: -- material.
However, the chamber
in the left-hand drum
to create the bassy sound
at that point was wood.
And then later on, as we--
as it evolved, it became clay
because the clay pot was
being played in the south.
Somebody had this idea that
if we change that to clay,
the bassy sound would
be even more bassier.
So, that was experimented
with, it went on for a while.
If you look at the pictures
of old like 18th century
or 17th century tabla player,
you will see they're
either wood or clay.
It is around 1900 something,
1902, 1903, around that time,
this experimentation
reached in the brass era.
So, the brass came to replace
the clay for concert purposes.
It makes them look good.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: It shines.
It shines and the sound
gets heavier and heavier.
And as-- If you notice the old
pictures, you will see that these--
the drums itself was a lot smaller.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
so, as the metal enter--
as metal entered the picture, you
will notice that it became fuller
and more rounder in shape and the
sound also improved along with that.
However, in this case, it's still
is wood but they experimented
with different types of
wood and they found the teak
or neem wood gives the better
sound when you put the hide on top.
And the one other thing, there
are lots of experimentation went
to get the clearer sound.
[Background sound] There
are actually three sound.
This keenar sound, which is the
shadj sound and the middle sound
which is called the maidan
sound, the swara of the tabla.
And then the black ball sound,
which is the flat sound.
And then, there's a resonating
sound, the conch shell sound.
So these four sounds, also
they're in pakhawaj except
that it's played differently.
Here, we rely most of
the time on the finger.
We don't use the entire
hand for the tabla
and it's difficult in
an upright position.
However, when you're playing
it like this, you're playing it
like this, this technique is used.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Slap.
>> Devapriya Nayak: -- this slap--
>> Yasmeen Khan: That's
start with the pakhawaj.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah,
that's the pakhawaj style.
And they've come up with
the same sound [music].
This sound [music]
and tabla replaced
that with this sound
[music] and as you can tell
that this sound is sweeter
than the pakhawaj sound.
So, in terms of the sound technique,
a lot of experiments
are still being made.
The Zakir Hussain has come
up with the fourth finger
sound, he's in tabla.
And just a little bit
of detail, in tabla,
this is what we call the workhorse,
this finger, the index finger.
The middle finger is
called the flat finger,
which is used for flat sound
also for the swara sound.
The third finger is also used not in
some gharanas, not like in Benares
for example, they don't use the
third finger, they use three finger.
But in Farrukhabad and
Lucknow, these fingers are used,
so that the middle and the third.
So, Zakir Hussain has
experimented with this a lot and so,
he now uses this one also.
So, there are certain syllables
for playing fast speed syllable.
He used this many times
and he showed us the
technique how to use it.
For example, when there
is a super fast speed
of teental or 16 beats cycle going.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yup.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
And he is using it
and it's creating the
same amount of resonance.
Of course, it requires
a lot of practice too.
But it's producing the same kind of
tone and the sound for playing that.
And coming back to your question
on the technique part of it
that evolved from the
pakhawaj to tabla,
a lot of changes had been
made in terms of compositions.
So, the composition that
originated in Delhi that is played
with two finger has now moved
east which we call purab.
Purab baj means the style of the
purab, the style of the east.
Composition has evolved.
Some are used for dance, for dancing
feet, of the court of the maharajas
and the, you know, different
principality later on.
Some evolved just for
playing solo purposes.
There is an entire
repertoire on play--
for playing tabla solo
which is called peshkar.
Peshkar came from the same thing
as we understand, you know,
the rhythmic format
follow a vocal format.
So in vocal, there is-- when
the instrument is being played,
there is something called alap,
there is no rhythmic
expression there.
So in tabla, peshkar is a
very meditative type movement
in the finger of drumming.
And slowly, slowly it
builds it up to kaydas,
which is a fixed composition
and then to relas
which is fast composition and
then there are guts which is
like a composition that is divided
into three cyclical patterns.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
these are just musical--
these are solely for tabla?
>> Devapriya Nayak: The tablas.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
they have a history.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
And the history goes from place
to place to place and as you know
that those days, there
were no internet,
there was no trains
or anything like that.
So, the gharanas grew around Delhi.
So, from Delhi to UP, Uttar Pradesh,
which is the next state adjacent
to Delhi, these are
where the maharajas
and their courts were settled
and all the gharanas are
around like Delhi is the first
then came the Farrukhabad
and Lucknow, which is the next two.
And then, a small village next
to Lucknow is called
Ajrara, which is number four.
And they all have their
special type of techniques.
And they specialize
on finger techniques
and then they teach their students
how to go about performing those.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, it leads-- you
know, it makes me want to ask you
to play some of that for us.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Sure.
>> Yasmeen Khan: But we're
not going to lose that.
I'm going to go back to Soumya
and Debu mentioned a lot and so,
I'd like you, if possible,
to talk about how, you know,
a bit about the raga structure.
As a musician, how do you approach
it, when you're going to play it?
The amount of, you
know, everyday talks
about how much improvisation
there is in indian music
but clearly during the concert
that you gave, you know,
you weren't improvising during
the performance, I would think,
because it was a short performance.
You have to-- so, can you discuss--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
I was improvising.
>> Yasmeen Khan: During
the performance?
Such a short performance?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, I mean--
I'd like you to talk about that--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Everything about it is--
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
how do you communicate
that between the two of you.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
So, I would say, in that
whole performance that we had
for about an hour, there
are these fixed, you know,
compositions that are almost
like used as motifs both
for tabla and for the instrument.
And they have a certain cyclical
pattern, like if you would go back
to the pieces that I played,
the first composition was based
to a seven beat cycle
called rupak tal.
And then the second one was,
you know, more faster, 16 beat.
But the point is the embellishment
of those compositions as well
as the alap piece which is,
you know, I am [inaudible] kind
of from rhythmic pattern.
That's all, you know, improvisation.
And if you ask me to
play it now again
like exactly the way I played
it, I would not be able
to play that, repeat that.
Because it was, at
that point in time,
how I was thinking and
expressing already.
The melody might sound familiar
because there's obviously the raag.
Every raag has a different
way of movement.
But it's-- This is where, you
know, I've worked extensively
with western musicians, Indian
music tends to differ a lot.
Maybe somewhat closer to jazz
but the other thing I was going
to say at-- too, when Debu was
talking about the various schools
of music, is our musical tradition
has been mostly an oral tradition.
And all of these things that--
He talked about the various
syllables and, you know,
whether it's various melodies
or melodic compositions,
up until about 70 years ago there
was no written history of any music.
It was all passed orally from
one master to their students then
to their students to their students.
It's amazing if you think about it.
And for a person to retain that
kind of music, whether it be melodic
or rhythmic or whatever have you,
in their minds and heads and to able
to pass that from generation to
generation without losing it,
it's an amazing accomplishment,
human accomplishment.
But then, you know, when music
was more formalized and especially
after independence of India when
it was being taught more openly
in schools, there was a
need to document that.
And so, annotation
system came by but it--
again, so, because it was
an oral tradition, there's--
there was a lot of freedom
given to both the precautionist,
the instrumentalist or
the vocalist to express.
It's a way of self expressing,
of course, there are boundaries,
there's definitely grammatical
nuances of how you move
around whether it's a
raag or a taal scale.
But then, it is all up to the
artist or artists to find ways
of expression within
those boundaries.
And so, if I play a certain
raag that has a certain scale,
I liken that to a scale
in western music.
But it is not like as formal
scale like you know it
like you're playing a C minor scale.
Because even within the same scale,
there could be three different raags
and just the nuances created by
the rest notes and certain ways
that you move around creates a
whole different experience for--
from an audience perspective.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Could you-- Do
you have an example of like some--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yup.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Speaking of
a couple of different raags
that use the same notes but
are played in a different--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah I'm--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Within a different
order to create a different--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Absolutely.
I can play a few-- and these scales,
the basis of Indian classical music.
So there are these 10 basic scales.
We, at least in north Indian
music, we call them thaats.
And then the thaats are--
they're composed of like all
seven notes in the scale.
And the raags when--
the ragas as created
by picking certain notes
among the seven note scale
and then creating some
patterns of movement so you--
the ascending and descending
pattern differ.
So, a very common.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] Sorry.
I'm just too-- This is like the,
actually, electronic version
of a tanpura, which is a drone
which keeps my basic key.
So, I'm in the key of C and
that's where I'm going to--
this matches my Sa and his swar.
So, we're all in sync together.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So, what
I'm going to do is play something
that is in the key of or
the thaat called khamaj.
And I'm going to play what the
khamaj that, the notes are.
[ Music ]
So, plain, do, re, mi,
fa, so, la, ti, do.
The only difference is that
when I came back down the scale,
I used the flatter seventh note.
[ Music ]
Now, using that and just by
removing certain things from--
as I go up certain notes
from the ascending--
from I ascend and then
positioning certain other notes,
I can create a raag.
For example, if I omit
the second note in--
on my way up, which is
the [music] and just play.
[ Music ]
I've create-- this is raag
khamaj, which is very close
to thaat khamaj but
it's very different.
So, I'm just going
to play a little--
a few bars then you can get
the essence of this raga.
[ Music ]
So, that's khamaj.
Now, what if I use-- instead of
the-- omitting the second note,
I actually going to use the second.
I'm going to omit the third note
and the sixth note
and let it sound like.
[ Music ]
That's a very different
melodic picture
as you can well appreciate
to a khamaj.
And it's called Rag Desh.
So, using the same scale, I can go
from rag to rag to rag and then,
in some cases, you
know, there are notes--
additional notes that are introduced
that are not natural to the scale,
they're called [inaudible]
swars or conflicting notes.
So, for example, again, sticking
to the same thaat of khamaj.
[ Music ]
Now, I've gone into another raag
that again has a different
melodic appeal,
it's called raag jaijaiwanti.
And this goes on and on and on.
So--
>> Yasmeen Khan: So,
the thaat is the scale?
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
The thaat is the scale.
So, it's seven notes.
[ Music ]
And within that, I can
layer in different notes
and also the way I am
playing those notes
and accentuating certain notes.
Like for example, the
khamaj raag was based
where there was more accent
on the third note [music]
and the seventh note.
[ Music ]
Whereas, in raag desh, the accent is
on the re which is the second note
and the mi which is
the seventh note.
[ Music ]
So, there you can see that that--
and the two sentiments
of the two raags
in the melodies are very different.
And that's how the
raags get developed.
And it's-- These are
traditional raags and of course,
people tend to blend
different things
and create their own
raags in certain cases.
>> Yasmeen Khan: How do
you decide what kind of--
what drum cycle or thaat is
going to be played with--
how do you guys decide that
with the raag if, you know,
if you're going to perform?
>> Devapriya Nayak: That depends on
the composition that it's set to.
And that comes from the
person who has composed it.
It could be him.
It could be his guru--
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: -- or it
could be his guru but some raags
that are like-- it's always been
like that that came for ages.
And that--
>> Yasmeen Khan: That it always
has a specific beat cycle.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
Yeah, a specific set.
Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
But I mean, technically, you
could play any raag in any cycle.
And, often, there used to
be a healthy competition
in the olden days when
the instrumentalist
or vocalist would start playing
and would look at the percussionist
to catch up and figure out.
Like--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: --
you need to figure out where.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And that
it's like a hide and seek game.
You know, the tabla player, the
rhythm person is trying to figure
out what taal or what
structure it is set to.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And sometimes,
it takes almost three, four cycles--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
To figure that out.
>> Devapriya Naya: --
to figure that out.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And does that
create sort of a healthy tension
within the-- between
the two players?
>> Devapriya Nayak: It is.
It is.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: It is.
It's all playful--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: --
but the idea is that if
you're worth your training
that you should be able
to figure that out.
Nowadays of course, people
discuss it and play, you know,
beforehand when they were warming
up for that-- before the concert,
they'll have a discussion.
And so, I would tell him, "Hey,
I'm going to play sevens,"
or "I'm going to play 16th."
>> Yasmeen Khan: But would--
So, the instrumentalist would
always have a good grounding
in the percussion?
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Yeah and I think--
>> Yasmeen Khan: But are you
unusual and that you have had--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: No, no.
I think it's part of our training,
and it goes the same way with the--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Could
you turn that off?
Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
It goes the same way
with the percussionist also.
He talked about learning
vocal music.
I think, the total training
of Indian music consists
of the vocal component, the
percussion of the rhythmic component
and then if you are
playing an instrument,
you learn some other instrument.
In some cases--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Actually, what I
was going to say is that, you know,
internally, when I'm
performing with somebody,
I'm actually singing inside.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Oh really?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
And, you know, and I'm also playing
it through my hand but internally,
I'm actually doing-- going
through the singing part and sort
of layering the rhythm on top of
it, which I could hear internally.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Of
course, you have.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And
the melody is very important
because not two melody is the same
and the type of theka that he talked
about earlier, you know, it varies
based on the type of melody.
So, in case we have rehearsed it
and he has heard the melody then he
would probably have figured it out.
But if we hadn't met each other
and we're meeting first time
on stage then it is really up
to the percussionist to listen
and that's why it is
so important to listen
to each other and figure it out.
Again, I say this going
back to what I said earlier.
It's and old tradition.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
It is based on--
and you asked a question as
to how do you keep in sync?
It's by hearing.
We are not looking--
Well, sometimes, we make eye
contact but mostly we're-- I'm--
>> Devapriya Nayak:
You're listening.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: -- listening
to where he's coming in terms
of his rhythmic cycle and where
I'm at and we're communicating.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And basically,
what the music is saying.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, could we--
would it be possible for you to play
and you to figure out what the--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Sure.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- cycle is?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Can
we-- and see that?
>> And you can turn the drum back.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And you can turn--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yes.
Yeah, of course, I will.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And I just--
I was just going to
say one funny incident
that happened two weeks ago.
There is a vocalist, I think, I
send you guys the invite to that.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: The
vocalist came from Kolkata
and she is a young vocalist and
I have never heard her before.
I've heard over the
internet and stuff
but I've never heard
her real concert.
And she started singing a
particular bandish, a particular gut
in 12 beats, but it's
faster 12 beats.
But the 12 beats sounded
like 16 beats.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Because
she was singing fast?
>> Devapriya Nayak:
She was singing fast.
To me, it was more like 16 than 12.
And she was singing it in
such a way that it was sort
of to play with me, I guess.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
That was the idea.
And a lot of time, it's accepted,
that we don't know each other.
We are playing for the first time,
coming here for the first time
and then we perform and we
haven't had a rehearsal.
So, that happened and I picked up 16
and then she said,
"No, no, it's 12."
So then--
>> Yasmeen Khan: And how did she
say that while she's singing?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Well--
>> Devapriya Nayak:
No, she just whispered.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Whispered.
OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
But it's all part and
parcel of the game.
I mean, you're not
supposed to know everything.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
That's good.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So let--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And there's
another funny story I would tell
if we have the time.
This is in many, many years ago,
when Pandit Ravi Shankar
was a very young man.
He and then, there was a very famous
tabla player Pandit Samta Prasad.
They were playing in
a concert in Kolkata.
And they were in the living room and
Pandit Ravi Shankar had practiced
with him something
in 16 beats cycle.
When he went on stage--
>> Devapriya Nayak: He changed.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
-- he changed it
to a 15 beat cycle called pancham
sawari, the same composition.
He played with the same composition,
he just pick away one note and,
you know, that made it
to a 15 composition.
Now, Samta Prasad had being heard
this thing-- and this was just,
you know, Ravi Shankar
playing with Samta Prasad.
He took off on a run
and without realizing
that Ravi Shankar is
playing pancham sawari.
It's the same composition, and
just think of the brilliance
of the man that-- and of course he
lands on some place and, you know,
Ravi Shankar some-- and
this happened a few times
and in front of a live audience.
So then, Samta Prasad just,
you know, stopped playing.
And then-- And almost Ravi Shankar
would, you know, smile at him
and said, this is pancham
sawari and then they continued.
But the-- it emphasizes the point
of listening and the concept
of listening to each other.
Yeah.
>> I just had a question about--
but then, you can ask
and they can edit it,
about the vocalization you said
that you sing while you play along.
Are you vocalizing?
Are you singing words?
Are you?
>> Devapriya Nayak: I'm
just singing the melody.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Which is--
>> You're singing the--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: You-- he--
>> Devapriya Nayak: I'm
just singing internally.
I'm not, you know, letting it out.
>> But--
>> Devapriya Nayak: But on
the tabla, I am layering it
on that part that I'm
singing inside.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Are
you singing syllables?
Are you singing--
>> Devapriya Nayak:
Just the melody itself.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Just the melody.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Just--
>> And when you would listen to
your grandfather and his students,
were they vocalizing--
they were vocalizing loud--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Is that right?
Yes, and during the rehearsal or
during the-- and it happens a lot.
I mean, let's say for example,
he's going to play a raag
that is set to 7 beats.
And the seven is not always clear
or accented, the seventh note,
you know, where it's
hitting the very first note.
In tabla language, it's called sum.
And the sum is not
very clear where the--
in the gut or the bandish
is starting.
And it's purposely done that way.
The composer have that in mind
that I want to keep it that way,
I want to create it that way.
And that's the beauty
of the history.
That's the mystery.
And so, when that was being done it
is creating confusion in the mind
of the tabla player so we
clear that up either the end
of the learning process
or during the rehearsal.
But imagine if it is not
cleared up in either way,
so we clear it up on stage.
So that there's no confusion
>> And does-- When
your vocalist came,
was she vocalizing with syllables?
Or was she singing chords?
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah
that's the question --
>> Devapriya Nayak: She was
singing-- vocalizing with the words.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> So you were-- with
some compositions,
there are words, poetry--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
Vocal music has a, you know,
obviously has a language.
Instrumental music does not have
a language and, you know, again,
there are two syllables in
sarod and you can create a lot
of different patterns with it.
But there's no language per se.
>> Yasmeen Khan: But you do
say [inaudible] for singing?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And then, for tabla
you have different vocalization?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Phrases.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Phrases and for --
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
But vocal music also--
>> Yasmeen Khan: And for a sarod,
do you have different
phrases or different--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
So, we have two syllables.
So, as I said, the down stroke which
is the [music] and the up stroke
which is the [music] and then,
with that, you can create--
[ Music ]
-- various types of pattern.
[ Humming ]
But the point is that you can
layer it into any kind of music.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
And your vocalizations would be--
>> Devapriya Nayak: My vocalization
in terms of melodic part--
>> Yasmeen Khan: For the tabla.
>> Devapriya Nayak: --
for the tabla is going
to see how it is matching
the melodic part that,
the tabla language is different.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah which is?
>> Devapriya Nayak: For
example, if I'm playing a na
which is this [music] or na tin tin
na [music] or na ton ton na [music]
or na te de [music], all of these
is matching the melodic part.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK.
So, the melodic part
has Sa Re Ga Ma.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right,
which is the voice.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And like he
said, there's seven notes, right?
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: I can match
those seven notes and come
up with a particular
rhythmic structure, right?
But I am humming it internally to
match my rhythmic structure to that.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
But also, I think,
part of Yasmeen's question was
that you do have like a ball--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes, yes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: That the
ball is the rhythmic pattern.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
And that's also recited.
So, there is an oral
tradition of that.
So, it is said in tabla and I
know this because I learned it
for a few years that you can only
play it if you can recite it.
And you can only play it fast
if you can recite it fast.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: But as a tabla
player, you have to know your balls
as well as the melodic balls
and-- so, that's a lot of--
and if you got a down set and
the down set has different --
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Right.
>> Yasmeen Khan: melodic balls --
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes, yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- and so, you
got to know what all of that means
and how it relates to everything.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Aboslutely.
>> Yasmeen Khan: --
which is pretty complex.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
And the fun part of it
is it's often improvised.
I can't remember if it was at
the concert that I played here
or at some other concert, in a very
fast section of the composition,
we were exchanging
balls with each other.
So I was--
>> Devapriya Nayak: I think
it was here [inaudible].
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
So, it's like a Q&A.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And
so-- And, you know, I'm playing
and he is responding and
then we come together.
So, that is done very common
and it's a tradition that came
from mostly from dance
and the percussion is,
but it also has crept its way
through instrumental music.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: That's
pretty interesting.
So, should we try and see if you--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Sure.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- can figure
out what Soumya is playing.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So, I'm going
to play a few traditional
compositions.
[Background Music] And there is
one composition that he likes a lot
and this one you can see-- this
is a very traditional composition
by a famous maestro in my school
many, many generations ago.
And it's set to 16
beat in the raag kamod.
But if you listen to it and
you can see the unusual pattern
in this-- with this count--
>> Devapriya Nayak:
I say that this--
>> Yasmeen Khan: So--
>> Devapriya Nayak: -- composition
was in the tabla language.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
So, it may not be 16 beats
is what you're saying?
You've got to figure it out?
>> Devapriya Nayak: No, it is
16 beats but you don't know
where the beginning
and where the end.
>> But you don't know where the
beginning and where the end.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, that
would be kind of interesting
if you talked through it as well --
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yup
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: --
while your playing it.
[ Music ]
>> Soumya Chakraverty: This is
the part where we're improvising
like rather he knows nor
I know where we're going.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
So, this is the unknown [inaudible].
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So,
what I played up until now is the
fixed part of the composition.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And you
could hear in that composition
that it has this unusual of stop
in the middle, unusual pause.
And if you are not-- if you haven't
heard that composition before--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: -- it is
very difficult to figure it out.
But it, you know, in the olden
days, it used to be played on stage
and yeah you figure it out and--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
-- come along.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So, it starts
from the, you know, the first beat
and he and I have practiced a few
times, played this on many concerts
so he knew exactly
which composition it is.
This is like the melodic
part of it, so he knows that.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So, you know,
translating that into
a tabla player's mind.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So, I'm thinking
[ Humming ]
Yeah, that's where the gap is.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
That's the stop.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
That's where the stop is
which is making the melody so nice.
But that's also a marking point for
me that is where this beat goes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK.
Which is my marking for that area.
And after that, I don't know
what's going to happen, OK.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And what reaches
that that goes into the empty spot.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So that, going
after the ninth or the tenth.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK.
So, we are fluctuating between
that and then moving away.
And then he could [inaudible]
area and I have no idea.
I'm just keeping the theka alive.
If you move the theka,
it's completely lost.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And I'm,
also as an instrumentalist,
listening for what he is playing
and I'm layering my
music to go with that.
So, there's a lot of-- that's
why we call it as a conversation.
And often, in a concert you don't
pick that up but there's a lot
of technicality behind it that what
he is playing, what I'm playing,
we're constantly bounding
off each other.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah, because I
mean, if you're looking at the tabla
in terms of sort of a western drum,
there's no clear, you know, beat,
structure that somebody who's used
to listening to just a regular--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- western
drum can actually pick up.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Because
western drums are very structured.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
there is no language to it.
So, you just pretty much
going by them, the sound--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Of
the bass drum, yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: --
of the bass and so on.
But if I throw you off
to a different intro
of style then you cannot
come back to that one.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, could
you play a 16 beat sample?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Sure
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- and name
the beats as you're going.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Right, right.
>> Yasmeen Khan: First, second--
>> Devapriya Nayak: So first,
I'm going to describe it
as one, two, three, four.
So, the 16 beats is going like one,
two, three, four, two, two, three,
four, three, three, three,
four, four, four, two, four.
OK. So, or we can say--
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
-- this is the language that
replaced one, two, three, four.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK?
Now, once you established this
rhythmic structure then you can do
just about anything and there are
like thousands of compositions
to travel around that cycle.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK.
So, for example, I'm just giving
you the beat and then moving
around to do the different
things, so.
[ Counting and Drum Beating ]
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
[ Music ]
>> [Background Music]
Soumya Chakraverty:
And you should talk
about what a tihai is.
>> Devapriya Nayak: A tihai is
something that repeats three times.
Tihai, three.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And something,
it could be a syllable
repeating three times,
it could be a composition
repeating three times
or it could be just a set
pattern repeating three times.
For example, there's a
pattern called [inaudible].
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
Is a tihai.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And you
can play that with any--
>> Devapriya Nayak: You can
insert that in anywhere.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Any rhythmic cycle?
>> Devapriya Nayak: In a
composition, rhythmic cycle.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: As long as
it's hitting the first beat.
So, you-- You're inserting
a repetition
of three whether it's the entire
composition or whether it's--
I'll show you the example of just
tihai applied in different areas.
For example, just a syllable
repeating three times.
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
I'm repeating a particular
phrase three times.
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
So, phrase repeating three times.
Now, the entire composition
repeating three times.
There's a small composition for the
beginners level wherein they learn.
It's called-- It starts
with kut [phonetic].
This phrase is called kut.
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
The entire phrase repeated
three times.
And you can play it
in different speed
and the way we keep speed
is by clapping our signs.
And the word in our language,
the word rhythmic pattern
is called taal.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
taal came from clapping.
>> Yasmeen Khan: All right.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
It's called taal.
So the-- Where we keep the speed,
one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16, and one, OK?
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, keeping the taal
in the same speed, or saying
it in different times.
So, that also has a different effect
and preparing the tihai on the spot
for it to match that one
is something that you--
>> Yasmeen Khan: You have to--
>> Devapriya Nayak: --
make, sort of workout.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Because the
one is the beat that is--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- everybody hears
that, that's the beat you hear.
You may know everything
else might just sort of--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And the
compositions in instrumental
or vocal music are also normally to
emphasize main note is that one--
it's the starting point
of the beat cycle.
Now, the composition may not
begin from the one but you--
it's always the main emphasis note
and that's where the instrumentalist
and the percussionist
hand off each other.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So that's--
that occurs throughout the--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Throughout.
>> Yasmeen Khan: --
throughout the composition.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: It's not
just the beginning where the--
that note is emphasized
but throughout.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
So, you may have something
that starts from the--
maybe the ninth note
or the 12th note.
But the composition
may start from there,
but the main note it
will always hit is the--
and I'm going to start
to demonstrate
that by playing something
so that you can see that.
So this composition that I'm
going to play in a different raag,
it starts from-- and I'm
going to give it away
and it starts from the seventh beat.
But you can see that the emphasis
of the composition is going
to be on that first beat.
[ Music ]
So, you could see that in
this case, that emphasize
of that composition was at [music]
that kind of that slow drawn
out melody but that was the
highlight of that whole--
the entire composition
and he knows that.
>> Devapriya Nayak: To him,
but to me, the marking point--
[ Humming ]
>> Yasmeen Khan: That's it.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
Now, that's the--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
That's the landing point.
>> Devapriya Nayak: That's
my landing point and that's
where the thing is starting.
So, to us, music is
talking to us differently.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: From-- To me,
it's the tabla player's language,
for him it's the melodic language
but the appeal is the same.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
you're syncing both.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
we are syncing those two.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
Just-- So, how are
we doing for time?
>> We're fine, it's
about five to four.
So, it-- are there other things
that you want to talk about
or cover, I mean, it's very--
>> Yasmeen Khan: I mean,
we can talk forever.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
That's the point.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And there's
so many things to talk about.
>> Thirty-four minutes left.
>> Left. And [inaudible].
>> Yasmeen Khan: We got
30 something minutes.
>> You have that if
you like to use it.
Come on make some gimmick?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
And, you know, what we could do
is demonstrate a few different
rhythmic cycles.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Well,
that would be great.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And
also, the fact that, you know,
I think I made this point during
the concert of how we can start
from a very slow tempo and then
it builds up to the, you know,
the very fast tempo and
you can go on there.
So, there's so many different
rhythmic patterns we talked about.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
There was 100 to 165 taals.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, this
one question I have though
about rhythmic pattern
and maybe especially,
I think, in the 16 beats.
They talked about the
empty beat, the khali?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, is that-- can
you talk a little bit about that?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Sure.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And see if
that is in the other beats
that you're going to talk about.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
And you should talked about not only
in 16 beat but talk about rupak tal.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Because it starts from a khali.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
So, introduce the concept of khali.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
So the concept of khali or
emptiness are no-clap, so to speak.
So, the way the 16 beats--
and one of the reasons it's
called the mother of all taals
because this is the first thing
we learn when we start tabla.
Why do we learn that?
Because within 16 beats,
all the other taals,
all the other major
taals are hidden.
So, it's sort of like a clue
to learn other taals also.
And that's where the
tali-khali concept comes.
And the way the-- the way
we keep tali-khali or clap
or no-clap is the very
first beat is clapped
and the fifth beat is clapped and
then the ninth beat is not clapped.
And then the 12the, 13th beat
is not-- is clapped again.
So, the way we keep count of that
is one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16 and one.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So, if
I use the tabla language,
[ Humming ]
Now, this is my formula
of the 16 beats.
And I want to demonstrate to you how
the other taals are hidden in it.
So, But you were keeping
the 16 beat alive,
now you're saying kaherava,
which is four beats.
So--
[ Humming ]
Sorry. This is six beats.
There.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So the
ninth is always dropped.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Wherever it goes.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
And the same way, if I'm
saying kaherava, which is four.
[ Humming ]
So, kaherava and then, you know,
there are rupak tal, seven beats,
nine beats and it gets
more and more complicated.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: But one
thing I'd like to clarify just to--
you feel-- I mean, he showed that
those other beat cycles can exist
within the 16 strike-- cycle.
But if you just want to recite
like he recited dadra,
which is six beats.
And then, you want to show
that same counting, it's one,
two, three, four, five, six.
So, the same clap and
blank technique comes
into other forms as well.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Oh, into
other beat cycles as well.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes,
because if they're your major--
the reason why I didn't
go into that is
because here are my--
tintal is my major.
The other is being played as minor.
But if I make-- let's say, dadra as
major and then tintal within the--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
So, you're overlaying.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
You're overlaying it.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And that's
where it gets complicated.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
But, you know, interestingly
not every beat cycle starts
from the claps.
So, I was asking him about rupak.
Rupak is a seven beat cycle.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: It's--
[ Humming ]
>> Devapriya Nayak:
So it goes like--
[ Humming ]
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah, so--
>> Yasmeen Khan: So how
does that work out on--
so, when you're playing the
tabla, your fingers do not touch.
>> Devapriya Nayak: No,
but internally, we're--
>> Yasmeen Khan: You're
not making any--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
It's a softer note.
>> Yasmeen Khan: It's a soft--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: We have din,
means-- I mean, also, in the tintal,
when he is playing the
khali, it's a softer note.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
It's not a--
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
It's not a heavy note.
And more often, he's
not playing the dayan,
he's just making a
tonic sound with dayan.
>> Devapriya Nayak: With the dayan.
So, it's going like--
[ Music ]
>> Yasmeen Khan: [Background
Music] Was that the khali?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
So you can hear the softer note.
As a audience, you can always
see where the tali-khali is and,
you know, listening if you know
the music then you appreciate that.
But the idea of the tali-kali
came from where there is emphasis
on certain beats and whether
it's softer or draw back on--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: -- obviously.
you still have to keep the beat
but, you know, since you mentioned,
there is also-- there
are certain beat cycles
where there is a blank
note, truly a blank note.
For example, there's a taal pattern
called dhamar, it's a 14 beat cycle.
The legend goes that it came-- it
was drawn from an elephant's walk.
Now, so, why don't
you recite dhamar?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
So, the dhamar tal is 14.
It goes like--
[ Humming ]
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So, you--
there are two blanks in there.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
He recited the--
[ Humming ]
>> Yasmeen Khan: So how is that--
And how does that work out on the--
>> Devapriya Nayak: On this?
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- tabla?
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak: It's
actually came from [inaudible].
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK that one.
>> Devapriya Nayak: So, this
particular taal used to be,
still is, sung with dhrupad, but
a lot of the instrumentalist--
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Let
him play and then I'm--
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
then he will do the melody.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: A melody
that is set with dhamar tal.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
So, it goes like this.
[ Humming and Drum Beating ]
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
As you can see the significance
with the elephant walk.
>> Yasmeen Khan: It
does definitely sounds.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
Just like this kind
of poddling elephant.
And the idea is that because
of those two blank notes
or blank rhythms, it can throw the
instrumentalist or the vocalist off.
So, this is the--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Their revenge.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: -- revenge
on [inaudible] revenge on that.
So, I'm going to play a little
composition set to raag kedar
and this was composed by
my teacher's contemporary,
a very famous musician
Pandit Budhadev Dasgupta.
And this, again, this starts from
the eighth beat but we can again see
where the emphasis
of the melody points
to that sound or the starting beat.
[ Music ]
>> Yasmeen Khan: Perfect.
Very different from--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Very
different, very different.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
No, but this is--
this actually gave you a
flavor of the ancient tradition
that they will talk about
which is the dhrupad style.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And
there's a vocal aspect of this type
of composition that evolved
into modern day singing.
But these are very, very
traditional and the composition
that I played is not
very old, obviously,--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Right.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: --
it was made in probably
last 15, 20 years ago.
But the fact is that that
composition reflects the traditional
style of the dhrupad.
And dhamar is a taal cycle that
was very extensively use in dhrupad
as long-- as well as with another
12 beat cycle called cautal.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
is dhrupad slower?
Is it more-- I mean, what is it?
>> Devapriya Nayak:
It's more meditative.
>> Yasmeen Khan: It's
more meditative.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
It's more meditative.
Actually dhrupad has a
very big component of alap.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: And even
before the percussion start playing,
there was almost like an hour to two
hours sometimes of just the vocalist
or the instrument just playing alap.
And the alap section, you had
asked me earlier, I did not answer.
There is a component of the
alap section, which is--
there are actually
four stages of an alap.
At least, in sarod vocabulary.
So there, the first phase which
is the most commonly heard,
which is without any kind of rhythm,
just purely the bars
being introduced
and as far as being introduced.
Then comes a part which
where there is a rhythm part
to it and it's called jhur.
And this also came from the
dhrupad, the vocals music.
Then, you start to, you know, use
some of that aspect of the rhythm,
it's not set to the beat
cycle but, you know,
you can hear that there's
a rhythm part to it.
Or no, a mellow-- a
rhythmic aspect of it.
>> Yasmeen Khan: To
the melody of it?
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
To the melody.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
And, I'm going to play
in a few seconds to
show or demonstrate.
And then, it goes into, you know,
full embellishments like [inaudible]
like you do the, you know,
rhythm except that it's
still at 20 beat cycle.
And then finally the
very fast portion
of the jhala, that's also played.
So, I'm just going to again, play a
little bit of alap in the same round
that I was playing kedar.
[ Music ]
So, I mean, I played a very
brief alap, but you could--
you could see how this could be
elaborated to a significant extent.
Then comes the jor portion.
How does that work?
It starts again very slowly.
[ Music ]
And so it goes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And so
that has a greater beat.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: So
I'm actually keeping the beat
or the tempo more to
say not olny beat.
The tempo through,
until that's come.
[ Music ]
And this would pick
up as I'm going along.
And when it-- what's--
gets to a point that.
[ Music ]
So, you can see that
there's a lot of [inaudible]
that is being [inaudible] but
again, I'm just keeping my own beat.
Not just [inaudible].
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: This
is the third phase of alap,
the fourth phase actually
goes into fourth scales alap.
[ Music ]
And finally, there
would be a-- so this--
this whole tradition that is now
played today in instrumental music,
actually came from
dhrupad, so they do this
through vocalization techniques.
And they would recite both.
And so, what I'm playing as
[humming], they would say--
[ Humming ]
And then later on, this
actually walk into another form
of singing called perana, which is
also taken from instrumental music,
went back to local
music and was molded
after and-- molded after percussion.
So, dhrupad has given
a lot to-- back to--
or it has given a lot of ideas that
have branched into different forms
of vocal and instrumental music.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yes.
>> Yasmeen Khan: It's fantastic.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And
the same thing with tabla,
when they are like-- the
whole concept of alap,
I raised it when I was
saying that when you--
when a tabla soloist is playing
table, he starts off with peshkar.
And peshkar is the alap of tabla.
If, for example, he played
that four stages of alap,
we also do the same thing when
we play solo and that happens
in the peshkar style when
we perform and the peshkar--
and the first part
of the peshkar is,
it sticks to the school
that it comes from.
For example Delhi peshkar
uses more finger techniques
of these two fingers.
Farrukhabad and Lucknow, which
I like a lot, deals with a lot
of meditative type syllables.
For example--
[ Foreign Language ]
And all these syllables are
coming from the Lucknow style.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And
does it-- is it.
>> Devapriya Nayak: And--
>> Yasmeen Khan: Does
it go from slow to fast?
>> Devapriya Nayak: It's very slow.
>> Yasmeen Khan: As well.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
You want to play some?
>> Devapriya Nayak: It's very slow
and it's set to a very slow tintal
or any taal for example, I mean,
peshkar could be in any taal.
But I can show you
a little bit of --
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
I'll keep the--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Peshkar
demonstration and this-- the tintal.
[ Music ]
So, that's an example of
meditative slow style peshkar.
I'll show you a mid part of
it, a little bit faster tempo.
Not in the-- And our
bass tempo is the same.
But the peshkar in
mid tempo moved up.
And will developing
on the same rhythm.
[ Music ]
So, this is-- This movement will be
developed into other rhythmic aspect
of it, but it's going to go in same
bass tempo, but a different set.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
And, while he's doing--
while they're doing the peshkar,
the instrumentalists or at least,
I'm also trying to adapt
and play something similar.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yeasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
That resembles the peshkar.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: So, it's the
time where he's calling the shots.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
Yeah, just the reverse.
Reversal of rules.
And then the third stages which is a
little bit faster just like he does.
[ Music ]
So, this is this the third stages,
and the last stages
is the fourth stage.
[ Music ]
And we can develop this
also or in a bigger style,
but in order to develop this, you
need to play longer in a solo event.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And, in-- OK.
And in-- When you perform
together, say like in May, do you--
in the middle of your performance--
in the middle of the
performance do you--
when the tabla player starts
to showcase his playing--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Absolutely.
>> Yasmeen Khan:-- do you
then go sort of recreate --
>> Devapriya Nayak: Lay low.
>> Yasmeen Khan: --
lay low and sort of--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah, you.
>> Yasmeen Khan: --
to a semi peshkar?
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Yeah.
So, I'm actually repeating almost
playing over and over the same gat
or the composition,
the fixed composition
and that's just to keep going.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Yeah.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Just like when he--
when I'm playing, he's
keeping going,
we do the reverse along the rolls.
>> Yasmeen Khan: And is this
sort of a modern development?
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
No, it's been there.
That way forever.
>> Devapriya Nayak:
It's traditional.
>> Soumya Chakraverty: Now, again,
there has been some
healthy competition.
So there's a concept of [inaudible],
where you can both go and improvise
without knowing where
each will say it,
but in your head you
have the beat cycle,
so you know where exactly
to come together.
>> Yasmeen Khan: OK.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
And then, there's another thing, you
know, the reason why I said earlier,
it's traditional, is because a
lot of schools for example there--
for example Lucknow, if
you're playing a Lucknow badge
or Lucknow style tabla
player, and you know that a lot
of times the syllables
are harder, and it sound--
it's got a ringing sound to it.
Because they're used to
playing with dancing feet.
And so, those-- the same tabla
players are going to play
with instruments or vocal.
In those cases, the vocalist
or the instrumentalist
they just let them go.
And they just play free flow.
And you can see those
images coming in their hand.
>> Yasmeen Khan: That's fantastic.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Yeah.
>> Yasmeen Khan: Well, I think
we're coming to the end--
>> Devapriya Nayak: OK.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- on tape.
And I'd like to thank you both--
>> Devapriya Nayak: Thank you.
>> Yasmeen Khan: -- very much.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
It's a pleasure.
>> Devapriya Nayak: It's a Pleasure.
>> Yasmeen Khan: There's no stress.
Maestros Soumya Chakraverty
and Debu Nayak.
Thank you so much.
>> Devapriya Nayak: Thank you.
>> Soumya Chakraverty:
Thank you Yasmeen.
[ Music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.